welcome to the program in 2023 Human
Rights Watch report says unchecked
authoritarian Powers leaving behind a
sea of human suffering it spotlights
abuses happening in a hundred countries
covering everything from war media
freedoms gender rights and refugees
among others it puts the war in Ukraine
at the top of its agenda saying Russian
President Vladimir Putin is operating
with impunity it welcomes the
international community's response
including the UN agency's collecting
evidence of war crimes but it says other
crises are being ignored and is calling
on governments and international
organizations to take action well our
correspondents have this update from
some of the countries mentioned in the
report
2022 was the year in which an estimated
1.2 million people came to Germany
claiming Refugee status the vast
majority of them ukrainians many of them
Thunder at Germany's Berlin's main
Central Station here where their
application process could begin but it's
estimated around 200 000 people from
Syria Afghanistan Iran Iraq also came to
this country the treatment they received
ever slightly different because
ukrainians have freedom of movement
around Europe those others don't
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
's political class is accused of denying
people their basic rights by failing to
address an economic crisis that has
pushed 80 percent of the population into
poverty low-income households have cut
back on food while the large Refugee
population has been hit hard Decades of
corruption and mismanagement has nearly
bankrupted the state which is no longer
able to provide services like
electricity Financial losses are in the
billions of dollars
foreign
[Music]
details a Litany of apparent Russian war
crimes including in butcher a town north
of Kiev that was occupied by our Russian
forces the UN served that at least 70
people were unlawfully killed or again
in Mario poll in the south of the
country Russians bombed a theater that
had been clearly marked out as a
civilian shelter hundreds of people were
killed including children
[Music]
230 Palestinians were killed in conflict
and confrontations with Israeli security
forces in 2022 and a further 9 000 were
injured those figures from the
Palestinian Health Ministry and that
includes those killed in three days of
Israeli airstrikes on Gaza in August
okay there and Israel is further
tightening the financial screw on the
Palestinians it now deducts more than a
third of the 256 million dollars a year
it collects on behalf of the Palestinian
Authority in duties and taxes